the monsoon season means one big thing
in India's southern state of Kerala its
snake boat season and that means
building and racing
this great big story is inspired by
Genesis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with a history dating back nearly 400
years the snake boat is a traditional
war boat in Kerala measuring up to 120
feet in length
these are intricate and not surprisingly
complicated to construct Liberty Sanders
hid or near the $10 fee routine very
simple look at cm per second now I'm
movin over probably an assertion that
sin duda if I just wanna hide all your
remaining today snake boats aren't used
for warfare they're used for racing and
in the iron will of festival the boats
are extremely ornate and can take months
to complete either plugin enjoyed on
al-quaeda codices network key in the
unfair under political opinion Sarah
sorry one was awesome
pretty good machine Elysium but at the
new are not in the shape food rather
than normally is sounding on them middle
kind of woody tutorial to carnivore a
new era factor with your honor
because of the boat shape they have a
peculiar method of construction we
contacted on 10 May and Okada Ani after
I come at 11 is Yannick atanga with
knowledge passed down from generation to
generation these artisans are not here
for the pay they are instead here for
the privilege of crafting these works of
art as the boats are thrust into the
water they are boarded by four helmsman
up to a hundred oarsmen and a few
singers who are there to help maintain
the rhythm of rowing is only at this
point that Santosh and his men can rest
easy
only one boy me to learn about Michael a
polo the name of look at is the oldest
Wanda Shonda Anwar another linear
Ninasam anthem an anomaly threatened
allah which is the tension will do
another local Perenara here Matata very
somber song
[Music]